what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and John here today
we just got out of the Disney lot they
kicked us out of there right away so we
are not shooting this on the Disneyland
we we've had a different background and
I I think we'll be fine here this random
spot in Burbank it looks fine we just
saw Avatar the way of water was really
looking forward to this movie yeah it's
a thick film it's a sick boy it's a
thick one so we got some talking to do
but it's gonna be all non-spoilers that
being said first off leave a like always
gotta mention that please go ahead leave
a like helps out the video secondly even
though the trailers don't make it like
Crystal Clear what the movie is exact
plot is it's really not that complicated
of a plot yeah surprisingly we will
explain like pretty much what the first
20 minutes of the movie sets up but the
movie's over three hours long so I
really don't feel like we're spoiling
anything but if you want to go and just
completely blind like to all extent then
and you should probably skip this video
not listen to any reviews oh yeah I'm
going cold stop watching trailers
everything here's what the the basic
story of the movie is Jake and the
sullies that's what we call them the
little family band right now they
relocate go away from being forced
people to relocate to be with the reef
people so they go way across the oceans
decide to live with them because the
colonel crutch he's back that was
revealed a very very long time ago you
can probably guess as to how the
Colonel's back but he's back and he's
out for Revenge he's got the military
supporting his revenge
full Fury of the sky people military
Avatar has weirdly become this movie
franchise it's really easy to be cynical
about admittedly I I had to kind of
check my ego at the door a little bit
when we were watching this film because
I did find myself like in the first five
minutes just like hyper analyzing why am
I doing this I need to I need to sit
back and take in how I really feel about
this movie and after adjusting I will
say that I think the movie It's self
there's so much about it that I find so
much stronger than the first movie
aspects of it that I don't think are
quite as strong but overall I would say
that there are aspects of this that I
think I would definitely siphon those
moments I'd be like that is masterfully
executed this is masterfully done and I
think it's overall like a better movie
and but it's not perfect there are
definitely like flaws that I want to
dive into there are Pros I want to go
into yeah John what's your overall
experience after watching this movie
yeah I'm a little bit dazed because it
is a very thick experience it gives you
a lot to think about and yeah like I can
understand how this would be formidable
for anybody but I was really surprised
by how much I enjoyed this and I think I
came in with a similar like I've been
looking forward to this and rooting for
them to succeed but you know sitting
down in the theater remembering the
first movie I'm like okay yeah in the
first 20 minutes maybe you're sitting
there kind of analyzing every detail and
being like when is this gonna get great
but yes yeah as you ease up on it so
like it really does become this
fascinating experience because it's true
movie Magic and it makes me wonder what
the sequels are going to do because
they're not each gonna have a 10-year
Gap to like level up on but this really
gave me that feeling of like wow I am
witnessing something groundbreaking and
on top of that they listen to some of
the criticisms on the last movie and
improved on the emotional experience of
it as well had all of that sort of
earthy communal spiritual air that made
the first Avatar movie so lovely to
behold at least as an immediate
emotional experience the innovations
that bring this movie to life really
feel like they're bringing it too like
you sit there and you watch and you go
this is like all effects probably and
yet it feels like I'm there that's the
happiest thing I could say is like
that's exactly what I wanted or rather
than doing the thing where you'd like
say other positives and then you save
the negatives for the end we're probably
going to be weaving in and out yeah
because because of the kind of Journey
that this movie takes you on I would
completely Echo everything that you said
The Ether of this film is so palpable
and there's such a Serene quality to it
the First Act of this movie like it kind
of feels like it's in a rush I was I was
surprised by like this is moving so fast
the visuals are so over stimulating and
we didn't watch this in Dolby Cinema or
IMAX we actually saw this at just like a
regular theater but it was still in 3D
and I gotta tell you guys I hate three
like I I loathe 3D I wasn't even a big
fan of the 3D of the first Avatar movie
even though everyone was like man that
three that did not really do anything
for me this 3D was so effective that I I
think early on I looked to you I'm like
I'm starting to get a headache because
James Cameron with this movie he he
plays much more with frame rates this
time around I don't know what the frame
rate is on this because it definitely
mixes it up throughout you could tell by
the motion of the characters and in the
first 20 minutes it took me some time to
readjust to it I feel like the movie and
I think James Cameron was intentionally
doing this it's kind of in a rush to get
to The Reef people because the second
they go underwater water oh my God
you're just like I think I said out loud
holy [ __ ] yes that's when the movie
suddenly just starts getting really good
and progressively gets better and you're
like okay this is something really
unique because it's a technical Marvel
the navi all the reef people they look
real like if you watch the first Avatar
movie they don't really look so real all
right but they look real as [ __ ] in this
textures alone are insane like you get
lost going how I how is this not makeup
because yeah they're not trying to do it
whether you're masking them in Shadows
or dark lighting the texture is
impeccable all the close-ups on them
they feel so human even though they're
not human but you get what I'm getting
at there and then the 3D really starts
to sing you know especially underwater
if you've ever been to like an
observatory or an aquarium where they
have those 3D shows it actually starts
to feel that way because the first movie
had its themes that it dealt with where
they used like the structure of a film
like uh almost a Pinocchio Pocahontas
and like dances with involves Fern Gully
this doesn't really have that structure
in fact there's so many different
characters in here that's part of the my
it's a minor criticism because I
actually prefer this film and it's
characters in this movie but the
structures because they're cutting
around in so many different characters
it doesn't flow as like as smoothly of a
narrative even though it all does come
together in the end in quite a
mesmerizing finale the finale is truly
suspenseful yeah and like you know
there's something about James Cameron
with water and wreckage you put those
two together he just knows what he's
doing here no no absolutely and it's
funny because the first Avatar movie was
one that taught me kind of what to look
for and how to appreciate 3D photography
you're absolutely right because the
first movie gives you this Wonder of
exploring Pandora and then this movie
you start the First Act in a place
that's familiar so you're mostly just
going wow it looks so much more real but
once you get to the reef and you get to
that culture that part of the world it
is delivering that feeling of wow I'm
experiencing A Whole New World and yeah
and you see it and you're like these
effects are amazing and whatever logical
thought you have but also the movie
constantly gives you this feeling of
being in the elements and like living
the life and yeah and I think the things
that sing best in 3D are things like
water and glass and times when you're
seeing through those things this movie
taking place so much in and under and
around water is like one of the best
applications of a technology to a
thematic element because it yes Taylor
Made to look great and to really show
you the depth of field but also to
transport you to the experience one
thing that I really felt with this movie
because I think you know if you
especially look at the people's
responses to the early reactions to this
film okay obviously the technology and
the visuals are going to be great but
how's the story there's something that's
very unique to Avatar and especially
with this movie it's definitely
applicable for the first film the
technology and the world and the mood
the themes and the tone the spirit that
in and of its self is a character of the
movie and because of the fact that
that's a character when you are just
exploring I feel like that's a big part
of the movie's character development and
on top of that too they introduce a
bunch of new characters in this film I
really like the leader of the reef
people played by motherboard
is these awesome the real stars of this
movie are the Sully kids and uh this
other guy I won't spoil it about it this
other guy who you see in the trailer
looks like Tarzan his name is spider the
Sully kids especially they're the real
stars of this movie because the second
act is most of the film and I think in
the second act you spend more time with
them than you do with natiri or Jake
they're all great they are really fun
characters to be around they're well
developed they're nuanced like the first
movie I wouldn't say is just like uh
they're just exploring but there's no
real necessitation for some of the you
know big sequences that they do I feel
like it's really well Justified here
because every big sequence feels
thrusted through character motive and
character narration I've seen some early
Reactions where people have said they
don't feel like it's quite as character
developed and I don't agree with that
one bit I think though and I haven't
heard any specifics I feel like that's
probably coming down to natiri and Jake
sure because while I think they're
really good in this movie while there's
a bit of a Last House on the Left effect
you won't know what I mean would I buy
Flash The Last House on the Left yeah I
was like oh these two is parents that's
cool
I did have a little bit of that effect I
like their performances but I do have
some qualms with the way they
specifically are fleshed out I don't
want it to sound like I think they did a
bad job because they didn't and when
they're there I like them that that's
the thing is when they're there I like
them but the motive for why Jake decides
to not fight back keep fighting and
instead retreat with his family to The
Reef people I just had a difficult time
buying the reasoning like they explain
it they do yeah from seeing what the
first 20 minutes was doing which was
surprisingly action heavy knowing who
Jake is I'm like I feel like with what
propelled you to move would have made
you actually go I need to double down
and fight yeah or at least go off on my
own and take up the fight even if I
don't want to put other people in danger
that being said though what they do with
him as a father and the scenes that he
has that's the thing about this movie
that I really loved is like when I
watched the first Avatar movie I'm
mainly thinking about the cool key
visual sequences I really noticed I
really like the scenes when they're just
talking with each other absolutely this
was this movie I liked just the scenes
there are some scenes and I was like you
let's just speed this up because like a
little over three hours you probably
could have cut out like 20 minutes but
then this is weirdly at the same time
there are parts of this movie where I'm
like well you didn't really bring the
you set this thing up and and that
doesn't come back around you can tell
they made some decisions where they're
like it's not not the bottom line
importance we can just lose that save it
for private R3 to wrap up or there are
certain moments and wakanda forever kind
of does this too at times an emotional
beat will happen and it just cuts away
like like the scene just like all right
we're cutting away to a new scene even
though I'm like if you just if you
stayed there for that scene that lasting
moment for like 10 more seconds yes it
would have just really left it impact
yeah yeah absolutely it's interesting
though it's like three hour movie you
assume like there's gonna be all the
breathing room in the world and then you
watch a James Cameron three hour movie
and you're like oh no he's trying to
cram so much into this yeah yeah there
are economics and budgeting you could do
for where you could you know remove and
replace things but I don't know for what
we got here I thought it was appropriate
and and what you just said about the
character work and stuff reminded me
like of a Just Right video I was
watching recently where he kind of
Illustrated the difference between
societals social storytelling Community
storytelling versus personal
storytelling and I feel like the trade
you make between avatars one and two is
the first movie is a very personal story
that works out a certain way you remove
that a little bit you dial back on that
and you make this more of a societal
story you know you don't spend as much
time on one character's Quest so much as
you spend time seeing what the life is
what they're fighting for what's worth
coming back to and what the situation is
that nobody can escape but it pays off
so well in the finale that by the time
you get to the finale not only is it
suspenseful and intense it's incredibly
moving sure because it takes it because
it's as long as it is because it takes
time to give you both the joys the
Wonders and the hardships of living here
and for Jake and natiri it's like yeah
the kids take the center stage in terms
of like the real thrust of the plot
ironically I like their performances
that much more in this movie uh Sam
Worthington and Zoe Saldana because they
are they're so elevated by their new
roles as parents like it's cool to watch
Sam Worthington be you know the the guy
trying to bring Justice to a system he's
learned is corrupt and whatever and
helped the people but here you're
watching something oddly more Universal
so you could argue it's even more
generic but it's just fleshed out in a
way that feels alive and breathing and
moving and rousing the scenes with the
children feel nuanced and I think when
natiri you definitely explore way more
what it's like for Jake to be a dad than
it is sure and I think a lot of scenes
with natiri like it's strange it's a
weird thing to have like a criticism
about because when she does them it's so
effective at the same time it did feel
like most of the time when you cut to
her she's kind of just like what like
she's her voice is worse yes this is the
most pain
like having a wonderful like learning
how to ride the water creatures scene or
something for her and then even with uh
Kate Winslet's characters the wife of uh
the The Reef people coronal I think
she's just kind of like intense she's
very intense yeah and very pregnant but
very committed to the well-being of her
people but yeah you want more of those
personal touches but those are also
things where you could go I'm excited to
see more of them in the future like you
know if we had to sacrifice certain
things I get why they did but it would
have been nice to have them I cared way
more about the characters this time I
did despite the the writing criticism I
feel like they just maybe had to trim
some [ __ ] really because the movie's
already super long I still really like
them in the movie while I feel like more
of the development went to the children
I feel like that development of them
outweighs whatever you feel might be a
lack of development sure everything on
the technical side brilliant beautiful
to behold the movie itself is mainly
like the theme of it is like don't mess
with the ocean anymore people like it's
an environmental movie by all means it
even made me go you know what I need to
stop whale hunting I need it I need to
stop clubbing baby seals man I gotta
give that uh hunting down those uh those
mantas in the ocean well that's the
thing is it does really beautifully
present its ecological message because
it doesn't beat you over the head of
with it in dialogue so much as it just
shows you this Continuum of people
living with and from and in harmony not
even Harmony I feel like that's what
people roll their eyes at living in a
cycle with the land where you've given
you take and you respect all that there
is and while the movie has some repeat
beats when it comes to without giving
spoilers villains I will say I
definitely hated the villain more like
in a good way like oh yes like I don't
like this villain and I want villain to
die I was invested I was very much
invested at the first 20 minutes and I
was like oh here we go and then once it
started really smooth out and then by
the time we get to the end I was like
wow that was a brilliant film and I
can't wait to watch it again yeah I mean
they gave him just enough of a Nuance
that he's not like you know he's not
like a fully 100 3D character but at the
same time he's much more understandable
and interesting than in the first movie
and yes just quick shout outs to all the
things that you would expect to be great
the sound design is just as equally
immersive James Horner's music score is
beautiful and sweeping as well as the
new bits too I mean you know yes from
from the other composer a thousand
percent Avatar is meant to be a
Blockbuster experience it's meant to be
a movie theater cinematic going
experience it's meant to be movie Magic
yeah of the highest record and I think
it truly excels more than the first one
if I have to choose between the two it
was a pretty easy Choice last movie was
done was like I'm going with Avatar too
yeah absolutely like no question like
even leaving the first one like having
those highs of emotion that the movie
gives you like this one I was like no
I'm positive that I like this that much
yeah I was really easy Choice I'm like
not only are there technical
advancements yada yada yada but I was
way more invested I cried a couple times
you know like I felt emotionally towards
it as well as you know oh cool movie
stuff watch it in 3D dude I think I'd be
saying that but yeah 3D best screen you
can find all right guys well that's our
thoughts on avatar the way of water
leave your thoughts down below uh be
sure to subscribe leave a like click
that Bell we will not be around or do a
spoiler talk to it on wedding day do it
on the wedding day live streaming from
the dance but hey that's where we're at
we'll see you guys soon
[Music]